[Music]  you love that don't you  you love Julie I cannot wait to see  gingers new look when she gets home I'm  not sure if Felicity is going to be  scared or unsure when ginger walks in I  don't know if she's old enough to really  comprehend that you love hey babe hey  baby  oh goodness that looks beautiful I love  it Wow when I first walked in I don't  know Felicity thought she was she was  just kind of looking at me  and then as soon as I started talking to  her and she realized oh that's mom took  her just a second though we got to get a  picture of it after yeah let's go take a  picture mommy  good come on Wow baby that looks amazing  I wouldn't recognize you for you if I  saw you from behind Oh ginger new ginger  oh the now a ginger I love ginger I love  ginger are you kidding me I think we're  now officially ready for California look  like a Cali girl perfect for LA summer  it is nice change everything's changing  we're changing our house or changing our  city our hair  [Music]